ich hab mein lieblingsteam die grün- und
krone aber kohle bringt mich mehr in
rage und ich habe auch einen gegner ihn
würdig aber nicht als lieblingsgegner
bezeichnen weil ich wirklich hoffe dass
also dieses bild sehen sie jetzt machen
wir schon wieder fassungslos ist handelt
sich um karl lauterbach und zwar beim
gruppenfoto zu spd-fraktionssitzung
sehen sie hier menschen ohne maske ein
tolles signal für uns ja mir auch schon
hohe impfquoten in deutschland und ein
mann sehen sie karl lauterbach geht
trägt die maske natürlich er lebt ja
auch von der kommune krise ich meine was
wird karl lauterbach ohne einmal vorbei
ist er muss diese masken tragen weil die
masse erinnert ja die menschen da
draußen die haben chronist wichtigste
tool für ihn als virologen und natürlich
kann er auch bei diesem foto nicht
darauf verzichten der menschheit zu
zeigen lasst uns über kroner sprechen
ich lache jetzt aber ehrlich gesagt
finde ich das schon ziemlich daneben und
karl lauterbach ist für mich der
hampelmann der woche ach was sagen mir
der atem eines monats nina wenn du so
über karl lauterbach schimpfte möchte
ich ihnen schutz nehme ich muss sagen
ich mag karl lauterbach weil er
authentisch ist und auch hier
authentisch bleibt denn karl lauterbach
will gesundheitsminister werden was
macht man als gesundheitsminister und
man zeigt was ist von dieser phase wo
viele deutsche immer noch sagen wir
müssen wahnsinnig vorsichtig sein weil
dieser virus alles verändern er zeigt
man sich mit maske weil man seinem thema
treu bleibt also ich halte es für
möglich schlau von karl lauterbach am
ende auch da wieder hervor zu stechen
aus einer neuen fraktion und worüber
reden gerade alle nicht darüber wer
sonst so die fraktion gekommen ist
sondern dass karl lauterbach weiter die
maske trägt und ich glaube die stelle
ich auch das ist ein massiven druck aus
der spd geben wird in richtung olaf
scholz bei den ampel verhandlungen wenn
die spd das gesundheitsministerium
bekommen sollte das dann karl lauterbach
gesundheitsminister wird eventuell ist
olaf scholz so schlau und wird versuchen
das gesundheitsministerium in kiew ist
jeweils ein albtraum habe willst jetzt
sich heute abend ins bett gehe den
albtraum karl lauterbach als
gesundheitsminister habe ich werde nicht
gut schlafen kann ich glaube dass karl
lauterbach tatsächlich kein so
schlechter gesundheitsminister wäre weil
er sich gut auskennt mit den themen im
gegensatz zu vielen anderen münster wenn
wir die maske ist werden wir
möglicherweise nie los wie in losen wie
dich du
herr lauterbach in der kann gern eine
maske tragen sagt mir ist nur wichtig
dass wir immer wieder reflektieren was
wir hier tun was passiert gerade oder
corona krise wir haben alle gelernt
maßnahmen müssen verhältnismäßig sein
sie müssen geeignet sein und wenn das
wir müssen uns wirklich ganz gut
überlegen wie wir das für uns
weitermachen für die breite der
gesellschaft wenn er meint mit dem ruder
laufen zu müssen überhaupt kein problem
sagt er nicht so wenn er sich damit
wohlfühlen wenn er damit wirklich hört
also ich würde sagen gesundheitsminister
werde ziemlich steile beförderung denn
aktuell auch wenn es die meisten nicht
wissen der karl lauterbach ist bei der
spd bundestagsfraktion letzte
wahlperiode ja nicht so beliebt gewesen
wie bei den talkshows der war er gesagt
zu in sevilla hatte glückwunsch aber
noch nicht mal mitglied des
gesundheitsausschusses fand ich immer
lustig er war mit mit dem
rechtsausschuss verstellt vertreter im
rechtsverkehr karl lauterbach
rechtsexperte ist der eigentlich nie
aufgetaucht vorher war wieso im großen
streit haben sie in eine damals aus dem
gesundheitsausschuss abgezogen aber naja
er polarisiert jedenfalls und mit
irgendwie karl lauterbach lästerei haben
wir einige kollegen aus - schlechte
erfahrungen gemacht deswegen sage ich
nicht was man in der ueckermünder klar
das müsste jetzt zuschauer also wir
haben wolfgang kubicki interviewt vor
zwei wochen und der hat gesagt karl
lauterbach würde in seiner kneipe als
staaten bezeichnet das ist in schleswig
holstein was ist die übersetzung bei
ihnen in mecklenburg vorpommern sind
natürlich nur distinguiert männer da am
stammtisch da würde man so natürlichen
übernimmt politiker reden aber im ernst
mal als cop oder karl lauterbach ist
natürlich umstritten aber bei der sache
jetzt mit der mit der maske ganz ehrlich
kann man mit dem kopf schütteln darüber
war ich meine gedanken sind aber ich
will dass seine reden
noch immer sei das wohl und haben
müssten mehr starten ja daraus guter
start karl lauterbach einige finden ja
tatsächlich gut muss ich sagen dazu
sagte seine ehrenrettung ja aber viele
sehen es genauso karl lauterbach sei das
sinnbild für maske forever am ende muss
es so sagen wie dies auf dem bild
gemacht haben sagen sie denen sie sagen
ja
holzrücken an sich immer gewehrt aus
aber dann nehmen sie doch wenn sie sagen
einige mögen die was sagen denn die über
karl lauterbach den mögen in ihrer
klarheit zumindest ein originales und
erkennbar ist in der politik und ich
teilen immer noch nicht mehr stand doch
da ist in ueckermünde müssen wir mal ein
bier zusammen trinken gehen
wahrscheinlich aber im ernst es ist so
und das will ich jetzt zu dem bild noch
mal sein ich finde maske freiwillig soll
er machen er hat jahrelang auf
freiwillig eine fliege getragen oder
hätten alle gedacht was das für ein naja
so ist auch im buchhandel
natürlich gut inszenieren am ende muss
es darum gehen das symbolhafte an dieser
debatte ist finde ich wir müssen schon
mal darüber reden wie es jetzt mit der
masken pflicht weitergeht weil da haben
viele langfristig kein verständnis mehr
dafür dass man sagt jetzt dauerhaft
zwang west freiwillig trägt karl
lauterbach gerne aber am ende glaube ich
müssen wir da auch noch mal drüber reden
und das war auch ein wahlkampfthema was
philipp wichtig war immer interessant
für pankow hat die cdu auch deshalb
prozente verloren weil sie so eine
rigide kroner politik gefahren haben
zumindest symbolisiert durch ganze
merkel helge braun wo man ja bis zuletzt
das gefühl hatte da soll es keine
lockerung geben immer aufpassen
aufpassen aufpassen und das mantra an
die deutschen die man blöd dafür jetzt
bloß nicht sein leben genießen ich
glaube ein gepflegtes sowohl-als-auch es
hat die leute auf jeden fall bewegt also
es war nicht so der vorhalt menschen hat
balkone alles falsch gemacht und ich
glaube wenn man sich fragt in welchem
land der welt hätte man eigentlich
lieber gelebt in den letzten 12 bis 18
monaten glaube ich da sind wir schon
ganz gut durchgekommen aber es ist
natürlich ein thema wo viele hin und
hergerissen waren in der frage
persönliche freiheit zurück kommt auf
das was wir köppel gesagt hat auch in
der frage wie sehen die ostdeutschen
eigentlich gerade das thema freiheit da
ist man besonders allergisch
gegen politiker die haben da genau alles
so wurde könnten glaube ich nicht lieber
in deutschland gelebt das habe ich so
mitgenommen auszulesen das sagen also in
den aktuellen entwicklungen ist
deutschland ein ich fast noch liberaler
aufgestellt aus die schweiz bezüglich
diesen zertifikaten
aber ich finde dieses bild hoch
interessant dass sie da gezeigt hat
gezeigt habe ich habe es nicht so diese
emotionen zu carlotta brauche ich den
wir früher glaube ich mal in der hat
sich zu vielen themen schon geäußert in
der deutschen politik natürlich immer
mit der autorität des unangreifbaren
experten aber ich mir nur dieses bild
anschaue dann ist das für mich ein
symbolbild diese ganzen corona politik
in dem sinn dass er ein herr lauterbach
antritt da steht der stellvertretend für
all die experten diese corona politik
ich vertrete hier die wissenschaft ich
stehe für die wissen kein politiker ich
bin für die wissenschaft ich bin
epidemiologe oder virologe oder so
irgendetwas ich bin die wissenschaft und
jetzt was macht diese wissenschaftler
der mit der absoluten wahrheit die
bundes steht was machte er zieht eine
maske und so zieht der diesem aus kirn
erzielt diese maske im freien an jetzt
würde ich ein lauterbach fragen herr
lauterbach
das war nicht im freien das war im
ganzen haus das war okay gut darum ist
eigentlich schon übrigens immer noch
gilt ok und 100 100
auf einem anderen bild zu sichten wo er
diese maus getroffen hat und dann würde
ich ihnen einfach fragen bringen sie mir
doch mal eine studie auf der sie zeigen
dass wenn man draußen steht muss man so
eine masse haben oder in so einem
riesigen raum jetzt kommt der zweite
punkt diese maske über die wir in der
schweiz auch philosophische diskussionen
geführt haben das ist auch ein
erzieherisches symbol da geht es einfach
darum den leuten zu sagen hey freundchen
diese anti hitze immer noch und kommt ja
nicht auf die idee und irgendwie
zurückzulehnen oder irgendwie zweifel zu
haben an der hoch womöglich in weisheit
der regierungen also er ist für mich
eher erzielen und auf die wissen schon
warum ich habe philipp lahm glaubt etwas
faszinierendes gesagt finde ich nämlich
dass dort wo diese politiker alle
standen zusammen mit karl lauterbach
eigentlich masken pflicht herrscht und
man fürs foto die maske abnehmen da was
für einen sinn macht dass der bitte als
eine woche sollen wird in dem
bundesjagdgesetz
den in den räumlichkeiten des deutschen
bundestages gilt noch die die haus
verfügung so weit ich das eher mit
masken pflicht also für die wege in den
gängen soll noch maske getragen werden
ich glaube aber auch dass sind bei
dieser ganzen und warum dann abnehmen
weil da ist man ja näher beieinander
eigentlich also ich glaube die haus
verfügung sieht jetzt nicht nur sieht es
nicht mal vor also ist das entwickler
haben jeder die politiker noch das würde
ich jetzt wirklich naja also haben wir
bei allem respekt endlich gibt es regeln
oder auch keine regel ist den man
auslegen es ist klar ein jurist kann
auch drei meinungen ich glaube am ende
war das jetzt nicht der juristische
untergang irgendwie der
spd-bundestagsfraktion würde ich mal
sagen aber im kern zeigt auch diese
diskussion wie schlecht die lage ist hat
können die leute nicht verstanden maske
war nicht beim restaurant wenn man dicht
an dicht sitzt maske ab beim gang
irgendwie auf die toilette die maske auf
das sind irgendwie jetzt mittlerweile
friktionen wo die leute auch kein
verstößen ist wissen sie noch carlino
bosbach wenn sie eine maske tragen
müssen und über nicht wenn wir keinen
fall so habe man bekommt aber hier in
berlin ist noch mal was ganz anders als
im rest von deutsch auf das gefühl ist
alles etwas entspannter und etwas
lockerer gehandhabt aber nochmal ein
später geht oder so also das ist
eigentlich verkaufen habe war aber auch
die ganze zeit so für die finde ich in
ordnung ist klar muss man alles mit dem
nötigen ernst begegnen aber wann ich
habe auch ein problem damit wenn man es
übertreibt weil das geht ganz schnell
dass schönes jegliches verständnis der
leute und dann kann sie auch bleiben ist
es gibt nur ärger deswegen immer weiter
hinterfragen und gucken brauchen wir
noch was ist angemessen und nicht die
impro techniken wir haben hier eine
anarchisten bei uns beim thema maske
mit einem persönlichen kampf gegen die
mafia führt und den menschen aber muss
uns doch mal ein bisschen erklären heißt
das jetzt bei dir mittlerweile wenn du
irgendwo hingehe ist wo masten pflicht
ja läuft
gibt es der situation wo die maske
durchaus sinnvoll ist zum beispiel wenn
ich fliege natürlich würde ich wenn ich
fliege übrigens auch freiwillig eine
maske natürlich mitnehmen vor allem wenn
ich neben der älteren person sitze ich
weiß auch nicht ob die person links
neben mir geimpft ist und das möchte ich
immer dazu sagen aber es sei eine ausmaß
angenommen und ich plane das würde schon
seit letztes jahr im herbst an wo ich
noch angefeindet wurde für die meinung
jetzt was passiert denn das ist ja
spannend also wenn wir zum beispiel in
einem supermarkt gehe es wohl masten
pflicht herrscht oder beim gang zur
toilette wie caroline buß post
du da machst du auf oder hinter einer
erlaubt war habe ich nur schal getragen
es wurde dann leider irgendwann
abgeschafft ist total auf die ist kommt
total auf die situation ein paar zum
beispiel ganz ehrlich da nehmen wir doch
mal mein arbeitstag hier heute wenn ich
durch unsere lobby gier die riesig ist
dann rege ich mich jeden tag darüber auf
wenn ich darauf hingewiesen werden und
da ist keiner in der lobby und ich muss
eine maske aufsetzen das ist völlig gaga
paul warum soll ich deine maske
handelsmann niemand in der lobby ich
mache die massen verfügung mich was ich
weiß weiß was das ist doch nur ein
beispiel es gibt doch es gibt tausend
das ist - nur eingefallen weil ich heute
den ganzen tag hier war es gibt so viele
beispiele ich finde das so furchtbar
dass allein am schlimmsten war am
schlimmsten war für mich ich musste vor
meiner haustür heinrich heidel ich habe
auf strafe gezahlt also musste heinrich
heine allee draußen im freien eine maske
aufziehen als ich mit meinem verlobten
hand in hand über die straßen gegangen
wo kein mensch um uns herum warten für
straffe worden ich weiß nicht ich hab 52
euro muss ich da mein kleines aber ja
ich möchte mich aber auf keine summe
festlegen aber ich sage heute der
berliner senat anderen dingen
szene passt jedoch ein beispiel von
meiner kleinen schwester habe einen
kleinen schwester die ihr wohnen
zusammen eine also in düsseldorf jetzt
hab ich die straßen er soll dafür
unverhohlen bedeutet und dann geht sie
raus und dann hat sie hatten sie ein
bier irgendwie eine hand und irgendwohin
gang als jetzt auch nicht mehr oder eine
cola light ich weiß es jetzt wirklich
großartig hand ist warm entsprechen das
war nicht ich aber dies genau so alt
sind wie ich und dann ist sie raus
gegangen wurde von einem polizisten
angesprochen sie müsste bitte die maske
aufziehen und da hatten sie es zu
getränken an der polizist ganz süßer
oder öffnen sie einfach das getränk dann
dürfen sie auch ohne machen das heißt
dieses ausmaß hatte schon angenommen
dass selbst die leute die es durchführen
müssen eigentlich ist schon gar nicht
mehr verstehen die maßen pflicht raus
ist jetzt weg um mein leben
die polizei
mit
[Musik]